i mentioned to you offline um that i
talked to elon and we talked about doing
stand-up that he's thinking maybe do a
few minutes of stand up say if you need
a coach elon i gotcha
um well maybe you should move to
austin's coaching full-time ah i hope
they can fly me in
so
what what advice would you give to
somebody who um who wants to try to do
five minutes like
the early steps
of uh trying to go to an open mic and
say something funny well that's the
irony of comedy is i don't know if it's
irony but it's like the beginning is the
hardest part usually the beginning is
the easy part hey i'm playing this level
of mario at start i jump over one koopa
troopa whatever and then the end is like
jesus christ i got 30 guys coming at me
comedy is the opposite the beginning is
like
it's a gauntlet it's just obstacles and
it's like you said open mics you i watch
these famous comedians on netflix and
you go this would all bomb on an open
mic they're killing in you know radio
city this would bomb it open mic that's
the weird part so it's almost you have
to go through hell just to get
to the the promised land and uh
i would say
rehearse the [ __ ] out of it because
you're gonna get frazzled up there
everybody thinks oh this is good
material but you also forget about the
other part of delivering it having
confidence
being likable having timing having a
cadence figuring out who you are figure
out what the audience thinks you are or
how they perceive you because you can go
up there and say all this but they go
why's the guy he's clearly gay why is he
acting like he's not gay you know that's
all now they're not listening to the
joke so like you gotta know how you look
and uh it's just repetition repetition
and bombing is not failure that's what
you got to remember i mean look if you
if you do a a killer hour and then you
take it to netflix and bomb you [ __ ]
up but
bombing is not failure it's just data
it's going oh okay i gotta re retool
that that didn't work something's wrong
there they i missed a word there so you
gotta treat the uh the act almost like
uh
like uh like ingredients in a
cooking in a dish you know like oh that
i put too many eggs in take an egg out
you gotta treat it like that and look
when you pull a bad cake out of an oven
you go i [ __ ] up but it doesn't hurt
your feelings but when you bomb and [ __ ]
up it hurts your feelings so you gotta
factor that in too your feelings gonna
be hurt and just almost be a robot and
just keep going towards that open mic
you know how scary an open mic is
bombing sucks but bombing in front of
other comedians is way worse because
they know what just happened
and they could have saved you and they
didn't
so it's way worse
and they're going to be your quote
unquote friends
for this journey yeah no these are evil
people
twisted [ __ ] up
people can you tell like in those early
days let's just talk about that like at
the open mic level that a joke is going
to be good on paper like i'll give you
my experience because uh
um maybe you can be my coach in this
particular moment so uh like larry
nassar
all right
that's that's fun huh
joking everybody i hope nobody all right
seriously
uh there's i now have an amazing team of
folks who helped me with editing and
they're now currently sweating watch
this you gotta leave that one in that
was quick yeah that's probably good i'll
eat that one that was good
all right so
uh you know
going in front of an audience just even
to give a lecture terrifies me uh which
which i've done
but uh open mic i mean that to me
perhaps that's why i like going to open
mics and listening is because i just
it terrifies me so much that idea yeah
of
going up there and bombing i mean it's
scary and to do even like one minute to
be honest is scary in five minutes i'm
also
watching enough open mics to realize
that five minutes is a long time i mean
it depends on your comedy
but if you're doing fast
stuff five minutes is a really long time
oh it's eternity uh i guess with a long
story
two is a long time because if the story
is not work you're building up to
something if the story is gonna fail you
just spent all that time telling the
story that completely went flat
completely got nothing i guess if you
have a series of jokes you can at least
try to recover and like do the mitch
hedberg thing where like all right i'll
cross that off yeah yeah
uh well i'm able to like i've tried to
write a few things and i'm able to tell
that it's really bad
well that's better than most
most people's egos kick and they go no
this is good now see i'm able to
introspect that like it seems funny i
mean i guess the thing i'm looking for
is original
like
there's easy stuff
that you think is funny but to me
originality is the thing you should be
looking for because then because then
that's what's actually
becomes funny like
or rather
if it's original
even if it bombs that feels like more a
beautiful art creation that you did like
at least you swung for it like you did
something unique because like even with
open mic your first five minutes there's
so many just go to enough open mics
you'll hear like all the there's like a
list of jokes that you just go to first
of all you can make fun of the fact that
you're an open mic that you're like
doing this the first time and so on
you could do a lot of stuff where you
make fun of your appearance in some way
yeah and so on but like yeah you could
do that
you know
that takes actually that's way harder
than people realize to do it in an
original way yes to present
who you are as a person
very quickly enough to then
put that person down in front of
everybody else so you have to reveal the
audiences like that because they go he
knows what we're thinking yeah exactly
um but do it again in an original way
and so like when i'm trying to write
stuff
not that i've tried long it's like 30
minutes but as
enough to see like oh [ __ ] the to write
something original is really difficult
it is what do you got a bit anything no
you didn't write any one line or
anything for this no well just in
general ever in your life ever written a
joke oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh okay no
but i don't have anything in my mind
popped up all right so the
the the jokes that i've written
have more like for some reason my mind
goes to like dark places so you know
like
and not actually dark in the mark norman
dark because you go
really dark
to where it's like almost absurd yeah my
natural inclination is to go to like
a dark
historical like place like hitler and
stalin yeah
and almost so go to that place
and then
talk about something absurd there
so like don't go like um
like all the way i don't know i don't
want to give examples because it would
be clipped but
but the mark norma style look it up he
has a special on his youtube uh
that kind i i want to almost explore the
dark aspects of human nature more kind
of
uh connected to actual historical
figures that's the
that's the inclination like uh i don't
know nature's metal the the instagram
channel that that explores like the
darkness of nature like like something
there
see that's good that you already know
that
you've kind of gotten to the core of
your comedy already and that that's
interesting that's a step ahead yeah i
can hear i mean with most things that i
do in life i can like hear the music
from a distance like in myself like okay
if you have anything
this is the direction it'll be yeah
without actually knowing exactly all the
steps and that's the nice motivation to
be like all right well if you do this
for a long time maybe you'll have a
chance to get there right but you have
to i that that's where the it's a
feature to be super self-critical i
think yes but then that's why it's
[ __ ] terrifying to walk up to a stage
stand there
and probably forget everything yeah
that's the other part nobody thinks
about just goes right out of your head
you go fight or flight it's ugly my
first years were horrific bombing
horrific stammering horrific not
remembering the punch line like you got
maybe you got a setup going and they're
kind of on board and you're like ah
how's that camera camera how it goes and
you just hate yourself it's it's a
nightmare but you've already kind of
maybe if you haven't done stand-up or
whatever but you kind of know your voice
and that's
yeah that's pretty advanced so you're
not trying to be somebody else i guess
yeah just for having done like podcasts
and lecture and so on that helps you've
i've embarrassed i already done some of
the work of the stand-ups do which is
embarrass yourself in front of others
for long periods of time yes yeah so
i've done that without actually
developing the funny right right right
but maybe the funny just is not that
difficult to develop
um no it's super difficult of course but
i mean maybe the essential work of a
stand-up comedian is just the
embarrassment of like finding who you
are yeah that's a part of it for sure
you know in the beginning you're like
water bottle what's funny about water
bottle i'm a funny guy i can make this
money but that ain't that's not it you
know it's it's your [ __ ] your [ __ ] like
your dark stuff for me
i tend to gravitate towards dark but in
a weird way where you know people will
say like hey don't objectify women but
then they go caitlyn jenner's beautiful
and you're like well wait
i know something's off here why can you
objectify her
but not the supermodel so what's going
on there and i like to play with that
so i have this joke where i say uh
caitlyn jenner
oh oh women go caitlyn jenner's
beautiful beautiful woman i go well you
look like her and they go [ __ ] you
and you're like there's a lot of truth
there yeah but i like exploring that
kind of
oh you're trying to get one over on me
or you're lying to yourself or what are
we doing here and i like i like that
kind of comedy
i don't see color well i'm black no
you're not ah
you know that's fun because you're
you're lying
you